Do it, my girls making me watch that tidying up. that thing on Netflix.
Oh, get out. Okay. All right. Cool. Oh, you can tidy up
snot a up.
It is.
Oh, you can. You can tidy up.
Hey Marie condo.
Not a biz.
Oh, you can hire her to come, but she have you seen it? It's on Netflix.
It's called tidying up. She comes in and she's like, okay, is she,
what is she? What's her Japanese dude. She comes in by the way,
it needs a translator, which is fine, but she's always like, okay,
I get you. And they just dump out. Get rid of all this. That's what she does.
Okay. Snapped up biz. And guess what?
It's not a TV show either.
It's it's it's straight up.
Bad.
Okay. Now, no knock.
No knock on the show. I know. I said it's bad and I'm half joking.
I watch it and. But this whole it's one of, you know what it is.
It's the new March of the penguins. That's what it is.
You made me watch March of the penguins and March of the penguins.
You know what? It was penguins, Dick and round.
Just shots of penguins,
each other and walking and waiting and traveling together.
And Morgan Freeman talking all over it.
I don't give a about that.
I got things to think of.
I.
Got a trial, a lot going on in my head.
I got to sit and watch pictures of penguins or cold and. And Morgan.
Freeman's like the penguins. I'm a notness I don't give a.
I've never seen a penguin. The.
Do I have to watch it on TV for so this Mary condo,
by the way, how's that or last name? Oh,
she must've married a condo.
It's short for condominium, marry condominium,
marry condom, marry a lubricated condom. So not funny. And so juvenile,
that was the worst joke I've ever made on this whole podcast.
It's 103 episodes in anyway,
Mary condo does the tidying up and she comes in and she's just like, okay,
I get rid of clothing and get rid of all this.
Thank this for being in your life. And then, Oh wait, what? Oh, I'm sorry.
Stop there. What'd you say you have to thank this for B.
You have to think this for being in your life and then get rid of it. Oh,
it's a vast,
Hey, you know what? I've never done.
Talk
to socks.
Okay.
Oh, but the socks are tired and you have to
no, they're not tired. No. Why?
They don't have brains. Okay.
So there's a way to fold underwear. I folded all the underwear.
There's a way to fold socks. Did it? Okay. Got it. Fine. Uh,
she,
my favorite one was,
but it's just annoying how everyone's like you're watching tidying up.
You're watching it. Yeah. Okay. It's fine.
It's exactly what, how boring and good you'd think it would be
little Japanese lady comes in and says, throw away and they throw it away.
And then the before and after pictures look roughly the same.
It'd be one thing too. If she was helping people in mansions and.
So you could see a real difference.
She's helping people in like two bedroom apartments, which is like,
so they throw away a few sweatshirts and some pots and pans get put away in a
lower cabinet. And then they're like, she's changed my life.
We have sex three times more a week now. Thank you, Mary condominium.
Thank you. There was one with a,
the best was she comes in and she, she,
I would like to start by greeting at the house.
Hey, Mary condo,
did you know a house is a house and it
isn't a family.
Did you know the house? Isn't
border patrol. Hey, this is house.
This is a house, not a cocktail party. So she walks in,
she greets the house. She gets on the knees.
That's the best one with the black family dude, they get in,
we reach the house.
She sits on the on her knees and she puts her palms backwards for some reason
and puts them on the ground.
And she sits there and closes her eyes while she greets the house.
Now do whatever you want. I, by the way, love her.
Love how passionate she is about clean. It's the, dude.
I listened to part of our audio book and the how passionate she is about
tidying up is absolutely awesome. It's awesome.
This lady is awesome. She really is awesome. I love that.
There's enough actors and actresses and out there.
This lady is so passionate about tidying up. She's the, dude.
She really is. This Marie Kondo girl is awesome,
but is just like, all right, so she's tidying up. I don't get it.
So she greets the house and the best was there's this there's this
black family. It's like this really sweet family. Uh,
and I just love when they,
when she greets the house and the black family is like so into it,
but it's so like,
it's so basically it was so Japanese the whole thing,
but it's also so something that like white people would be like,
this is really the new thing. This is it. We greet the house,
we thank our socks and we say,
good morning to our ball caps and our pots and
pans. We use them and we love, we actually love them.
That's such a like white thing to adopt from, uh,
from Japanese culture and for it to become a fad for a year and then forget
about it. Right. Okay. But, and black people don't do that.
And it's so funny that the black family is there and she's greeting the house.
And even though they seem all into it, I like to imagine that there's like this,
the, the, the uncle that they don't show like, yeah. Right.
You know, he, he lives in like the side room and, but they're like, yeah,
you could do a show at is tidying up. But you know, I don't feel me.
I got my own space. I ain't tidying up. So if they still want to do it,
then they want to do it. And then that, he's just like behind the camera crew,
like in the corner, just like watching. And she's like,
so it's time to greet the house. And he's just like, and, and EV and the,
and the, and the is just like this. And the kids are like this and the,
the black dad who's practically white is just sitting there like this.
And the lady is like the black lady sitting there like this.
And then there's like, the uncle that stays with them.
That's like the guy that just, and he's just like, okay, look. Um,
and they cut all these parts out, but he's just like, Oh,
go and thank the house. Okay.
Oh, she go, Oh.
I don't know. Um, what y'all.
Just.
To say, like, you know, I noticed a show and we go and do for the show,
but speech is thanking. This is greeting the house.
Yo. I'm like, it's all good. You know, I don't want to say nothing, but
just basically it'd be tagging. I know you're doing your show,
but can I talk to you for a second, Charles, come over here. Hey, we got,
we got in here. We got bridges in here. Green houses.
You understand what I'm saying? And you were acting just for the cameras.
I get it. But you need to tell me right now, are you with this green the house?
Or do you understand that? What it's doing is some Japanese.
And he's why people go and take it and run with it. Oh, you. You understand?
We don't do this. Oh,
we thank his socks now, you know, he's in the backroom. We thank each underwear.
We thank the shirts. We sh we thank
these. The jeans. You don't need that anymore. And then the,
and then the uncle who is in the side room, just like this, eating a bowl,
eating popcorn, just like looking, just like this. Thanking the of jeans,
Speech tank in a pair of jeans. Um, I, I ain't even trying to interrupt,
but like they cut this part out D okay. Let me just get in here. I'm sorry.
So sorry, crew member. Let me grab the, this. These are my jeans.
I don't know how to, how to got mixed up with Charles as geniuses,
but I'm gonna take these jeans. I don't want you talking to my, excuse me.
Thank you. Excuse me. Thank you, Mary. I, these, these margins,
I don't want you even talking to my jeans. Like they real people.
These are my jeans. Okay. I'm gonna take this.
I'm gonna put in my corner that I do not want you to touch. Now.
I gotta run a Rite aid and I gotta grab some. And, and guess what?
I'm I grabbed some I don't even need, but I'm gonna keep it in my,
in my room right here. And you ain't going to go in here. Okay? Yeah.
I got extra. Like there's a bottle opener right here. It's in my bedroom.
Why the? A bottle opener in my bedroom bedroom. Guess what?
I don't know if I was as crazy as you could probably ask this.
It's a bottle opener. You going to ask this bottle of Abe? Hey,
this is if I was you, Hey, what's up? Why are you in his bedroom? Oh,
I don't know. I'm a bottle opener. How about that? Mary condominium?
What the is wrong with you?
I'm going to keep this bottle open and next to my bed in case I want,
look empty bottles right here. Right here at the foot of my bed right here.
We ain't get rid of it. That's what we doing. We keeping it right there.
I used the bottle open, open that. And I got to be right here. That's warm as.
I'm gonna keep it here. I ain't got no fridge in here.
And if I take it and put it in a fridge, you ain't going to get rid of it.
And if you do you, ain't gonna thank it. Cause this my.
You ain't gonna do your Japanese white people over here.
And they cut that part out and they film crews, just like, just let them,
let them go. Let them go. Let them go. And then there's a black filmmaker.
And he's like, and you know what the this is, man.
You know what the these doing?
I know you got a job to do and you're holding the camera,
but you notice crazy thanking these jeans. Give me my Jean. These are mine.
Give me the belt. That's mine too. With the jeans. Give it, give it to me.
Don't talk to my belt. Don't go on my room. I'm keeping it. This,
a mess, dude. My phone is walking out,
talking to clothing and thinking houses, green as houses, man.
Yeah.
Up my life. And he's in his bedroom just by himself at a condo in my life, man,
brainwashing, these. I remember when we used to just save bottle caps, man.
We used to save stamps to get rid of that. The, my purple shorts go.
I like not being able to find.
Tidy up.
My tidy up my dog is my mess in this.